[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum uh
this is the second time i'm doing an
intro because uh we started to record
and then
yeah yeah we we realized that the new
talk
talk the podcast that we have on
wednesdays it's called talkville and the
talkville sign was up and we didn't
realize it in the wide shine so now we
have to re-record this but you should i
didn't even need to tell you that
because you didn't need to know and
you're listening but you're listening
you don't care guys thank you for
listening to this podcast thank you for
tuning in each week there's so many
podcasts you tune in to us
whether it's tuesday when we come out or
whether it's a weekend whatever you make
your make time for this podcast and it
means the world to me and i couldn't i
couldn't do it without you if you're
just here for cassidy freeman i hope you
stick around please subscribe write a
review it helps the podcast so much our
handles are
at inside of your pod on twitter and
cyberpodcast on instagram and facebook
that's exactly right and we love
messages we love
reviews and spread the word um also i'm
on cameo if you want to say hello to me
or i could say hello to you and a happy
birthday uh also the inside of you
online store has a bunch of awesome new
stuff a new zip up jacket
smallville merch lex miss scripps
smallville stuff signed uh
uh mugs glasses tons of cool stuff get
on the inside of you online store also
patrons i couldn't do this podcast
without you you know that i tell you
every week
these are folks who would join my
patreon which is patreon.com inside of
you and i'll message you after you join
you really help the podcast and part of
the top tiers is i read your names out
at the end of the podcast other perks
too and things i'm actually zooming
all of my top tier patrons uh
tomorrow cool yeah very soon they'll be
nice i'll get on the get on the video
with all of them and say hello and thank
you and and see what they're up to and
uh that will be nice uh also the band
sunspin my band my album's coming out
soon so keep looking sunspin.com it's
probably gonna come out in september uh
maybe a little later we're finishing it
up it's really good the actual theme
song on the talkville podcast is uh it's
the instrumental for a song we have on
the album so it's really cool
and uh what else i will be in august at
fan expo boston august 12th weekend
doing smallville nights with tom willing
lots of other great stuff trying to deal
with my anxiety
i hope you're dealing with your anxiety
i hope you're dealing with life and
taking things in stride and trying to
enjoy things more ryan how are you i'm
also trying to enjoy things more as well
yeah yeah
just playing your sports you're playing
playing on wednesday nights doing my
little exercises
that's good that's yeah it no it does
help it's good yeah i'm excited for my
soccer game i play goalie never played
goalie before i love it it's awesome how
many times do you play uh i mean once a
week really yeah
and you're doing all right yeah i'm
enjoying it wow yeah that's a big role
to take on a goalie you know i i always
wanted to play uh
little league well literally version of
soccer whatever that is i tried out when
i was like
eight years old and that didn't make it
uh no and then but i stayed on the same
team like till i was like 14
and so it was just this one kid who got
to be going the whole time i played
defense it was a great team uh nice kids
but i really wanted to play golia and uh
now i can now you can you're making your
dreams come true
i love it i love it well guys thank you
again for sticking around and uh
subscribe all that stuff keep listening
cassidy freeman this is a fun interview
she's great righteous gemstone she was
on smallville we talked about that she
kind of took over from my character lex
luthor we talk about that we talk about
life
and everything else in between let's get
inside of cassidy freeman it's my point
of view
you're listening to inside of
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
wow
i got the privilege of meeting the baby
gigi
good
what a damn treat that was she is
you know i hate to say it i mean i know
i don't hate to say it but don't you
hate when people are like oh here's my
new baby and you're just like oh my gosh
your baby's so
cute this is the cutest little but like
your kid is actually incredibly cute
thank god
because that would be a god i mean i'd
have to lie probably wouldn't i'd
probably have to say oh my gosh look at
that
yeah you would have to lie and i don't
think you'd be that bad at it but i i do
think i would i would sense that you
were lying
would you especially if i went oh if i
said oh would you look at that
look at that would you look at that but
gigi is adorable you said gigi's good on
planes
she's great on planes she's great on set
she's great in my trailer i think she
sleeps better in my trailer
than she does in her room
or our room because i share a room
right so she you keep her with her on
set for the righteous gemstones you keep
her on set in the trailer
not every day
but i did have the woman who's helping
me out bring her
uh a couple days just to sort of like
know if it was possible is that called
the nanny or is it just the woman it is
can we find it the woman i call her my
sandy or the woman the woman
the woman
i just feel isn't nanny a weird word
or or i'm just not accepting the fact
that i'm no longer 15 and i have a nanny
that works for me how old is gigi by the
way how old is gigi
she's four and a half months four and a
half months now see i i we were talking
about this before but
people have this whenever you ask them
how old is oh my baby's 67 weeks
i'm like what does that mean why are you
going with that man i don't even know
how much no a woman a woman did this to
me on the plane yesterday she was like
how old's yours and i was like four and
a half months and she's like um we're 47
weeks so i was like i know four eight
twelve sixteen twenty
that's almost a year that's almost 10
months
anyway or something like that they do
this they do there's a reason they do
this yeah i want to hear the reason
please don't know this reason the reason
they do this is because um at least what
i think pregnancy is uh done by my by
weeks instead of months because truth be
told if you did like how long is it we
always hear nine months right nine
months gestation you carry a baby for
nine months the truth is you actually
carry a baby for 10 months
but it's really nine and a half months
because and i mean this is pretty
apropos given the last week we've just
had but a woman
starts
their pregnancy two weeks before they
actually conceive
so you are a month pregnant you're
actually only two weeks since conceiving
but that's how they that's the only way
they can like
doctors can measure it and know when you
should be giving birth or when you
shouldn't be giving birth and where the
growth should be of the fetus to make
sure the fetus is okay and all of that
how many uh ryan's calculating this how
many weeks am i ryan
50 times 52
2600 2600 weeks folks michael rosenbaum
is 2600
weeks today or actually july 11th um
well no
is your birthday july 11th july 11th is
my birthday 7 11. i get free slurpees
but doesn't at 7-eleven don't doesn't
everybody get free slurpees at 7-eleven
on 7-eleven
does everyone say slurpee with an eight
did i do that did i say
you didn't you didn't be there
do you do you recall how we met
yeah i mean look there's when we
actually met
and then there's like the months
preceding that where i felt like i knew
you because no one could speak to me
without saying your name
is that true
yeah so you and we'll get i want to get
into you know you growing up in cassidy
freeman as a young girl what was going
on and how all that happened because
that's kind of like i wanna i wanna hear
the story i wanna know like what you
were like and all this stuff but
you and look we can get into this model
stuff now but like we met because your
old agent i don't think she's your agent
anymore
schmidt schmidt
she's still your agent she's not your
agent but she called me and said hey
you know my my uh client um
cassidy freeman is taking over for your
role she didn't say it like that she
just said you know that she's a new
character on smallville and you've left
and you know she'd like to you know i'd
love if you just have a chat with her so
i remember that and i remember we had a
chat
do you remember what the chat
consisted of
i don't i do i know i want you
bless you ryan i was really stoned a lot
that time in my life you were really
stoned
what
were you a pot smoker you don't appear
to be a pot smoker
how what does a pot smoker appear to be
like you know someone who appears to be
stoned
you never like you came across you just
always seem like very professional very
with it not that you're not not that pot
smokers can't be with it i'm just saying
i didn't know but tell me what the
conversation was about let's let's leave
my drug used to it i think we'll get
into your drug use and you're you're
real we will sincerely uh i you know i
think it was just like what can i expect
you know i'm going up to vancouver to
shoot this and i said listen it's the
hardest job in the world is stepping in
as a guest star
that's the hardest thing you can do
is go on to a television series that's
already established and say hey here i
am i'm cassidy freeman i'm taking over
for michael rosenbaum sort of and i'm
playing his sister that's how it was
always yeah that's how it was always
described and i just said hey the crew
is great and the cast is great they're
going to be really warm to you
and
but i was lying
because uh no i wasn't i was lying but
what was your experience like
you know do you remember like
were you nervous you had to have been
nervous
absolutely i was nervous i had literally
done one guest star and one pilot before
booking that in my life that's it
that's it
so i had no idea and and the palette
that i've done before
becoming test mercer was um
another pilot for the cw that i did with
justin hartley
so i weirdly had a touchstone coming
with me the fact that he was coming on
as a series rag
with me um
and
it was terrifying also weirdly moving to
canada was difficult uh like in us in
the world of cell phones and rents
i was still so young like i didn't know
how old were you apartment how old were
you 20 24
24 i think i started smalling when i was
26 or 27.
that's crazy
i mean you are a kid still you're a kid
and now you're thrusted up
into canada
vancouver where it rains 90 of the time
and you're playing this character in the
seas established show and starting
season eight
yeah
yeah everyone was really nice to me you
know the but it did feel very lonely
sometimes because um you know tom's
awesome but he's a pretty private person
and we developed a really sweet sort of
like brother-sister relationship
um maybe because he felt bad for me but
um
we also both like we're both kind of
chill people so we got along really well
but he's not gonna be like hey let's
hang out um
and justin i also had that relationship
with justin i tend to hang out with
dudes more
um than i do with women uh
and i don't know if that's because like
i'd rather go out for a beer than like
get my nails done but um and that's very
um that's a total like
uh generalization but but have you
always been like a tomboy you've always
been that way yeah yeah i grew up with
brothers i just feel more comfortable i
felt more comfortable with that and i
think honestly i think women in this
industry kind of scared me
um because i didn't know if they were
gonna like be nice to me or eat me
i don't want to step out of line here
but
isn't that true i always felt like you
got an audition and dudes are just kind
of dudes like what's up all right okay
man great they go in the audition and i
always felt like women were kind of like
that [ __ ]
you know but did you feel like that is
that is that a true thing that just
based on what i have talked with my
friends that are women that have
expressed their experiences that's sort
of how i came up with that
absolutely and not only that the that
[ __ ] is based in the re like the truth
about the seed of that reaction is
actually
i'm wildly insecure and i think that
that other woman is more
fill in the blank attractive tall right
for the part wearing the right thing
skinny you know voluptuous whatever you
want to say i'm gonna it's all out of
comparison
and i think that's what i um
i was like hesitant i like didn't want
i don't know man i just uh i just
treaded lightly but um i i always refer
to smallville as sort of like my grad
school
because
they were like it's only gonna go a year
yeah right and it went three and um
i just kind of stayed up there and i
watched i watched a lot i was very
observant
sometimes people would be like
you don't work today why are you on set
and i would be like i don't know what
i'm doing half the time and i want to
learn
really you were that you felt like you
were that green like you'd only done a
guest star on something else and you
felt like you wanted to learn and this
is a great
chance for you to learn on set
i'm the kind of person that studies the
root of where i'm driving before i put
it into google maps like i want to know
what the steps are before i get there
because i don't want to be unprepared
you're smart that's really smart i don't
i just jump in the car and i go in fact
i go to some of these conventions or
whatever and i don't know where i'm
going half the time and i land and i go
just take me where i'm supposed to go
point in the direction where i'm
supposed to be what i'm supposed to do
and i'll just do it i just don't want
the stress of knowing where i'm going
but then i think you missed you miss out
on
being present a lot of times like this
is where i am this is where i'm going
let's have a i don't like to plan
everything but i think i could be better
at that
no and i think i i totally hear you i
also think it's like if you're the kind
of person that's okay with not knowing
where you are where you're going then go
with it right if i could do that you
call it smart i call it high functioning
anxiety but you know potato picado
that's amazing
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts well that's different well it's
completely different
just uh being
depleted depleted of energy overworked
overworked not making enough time for
yourself yep have you guys felt burnt
out i i know i have i constantly feel
burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yeah
listen to better help
um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
um i know
that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back in the bedroom and just fall on my
bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ] if i
could say that i don't think better help
it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um
talking to a therapist talking to
someone
someone who's objective someone who can
you know who listen to you who's a
professional it helps it really truly
helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take
take uh all the patrons and all the
people around the world that use better
help yeah take their word for it yeah
um better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
our listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help better help
dot com slash
inside
inside of you is brought to you by
con air
turbo extreme steam and iron two in one
oh man this thing is awesome this is the
most powerful handheld steamer i've got
it right here because it's so cool
look at this look how beautiful this is
so easy to use ryan
it's the most powerful handheld steamer
fast and easy wrinkle removal
extra large sole plate can be used
vertical or horizontal also works
without steam as a dry iron
advanced heat technology is ready almost
instantly and obliterates wrinkles with
turbocharged dry steam you don't
understand i don't go to the dry
cleaners i don't have time for it i'm
single
okay
this thing helps me
you add a little water
you're you're going within seconds and
your clothes look like nice you can go
out
this is so easy and beautiful look at
this thing
i recommend it highly
uh it's got four settings for delicate
to turbo it's perfect for all fabrics
kills 99.9 percent of bacteria sanitizes
around the house and refreshes clothing
easy to use great for at home or on the
go go to amazon and search for conair
turbo extreme steam you will not be
sorry this is a great product go to
amazon search for conair turbo extreme
steam
so you went up there
blindly and i you know besides a little
conversation that we had do you remember
the first time you got on set on
smallville and you had to act and you
remember what was racing through your
mind and trying to breathe what was
going through your mind
kevin fair was directing the episode oh
kevin fair
i was um i was in my office your office
at the luther mansion and i was like
we it was a scene it wasn't like the
first time you saw tess mercer but we
were shooting out of order that episode
it was the first time that she meets
lois lane
and erica who is just a gem of a human
being was so kind to me that is one
woman that like
immediately i was like she's got my back
she is she's like that and i think also
because she she deals with anxiety we
talked about on the podcast she deals
with a lot of anxiety and she you know
and i think that she plans things out a
lot like you do but um
yeah you're right she is she's a she's a
different breed she's just a really
she's so down to earth yeah she's also
incredibly gorgeous and yes
that unfortunately makes her a target
and i think she
has
uh done really well with that with being
a target i think she is really genuine
and authentic
and kind what do you mean when you say a
target exactly
you know like
again i i can't make like a comparison
when i think about dudes because it's
not like dudes say like oh that guy is
such a six-pack i'm gonna [ __ ] him up
like i'm gonna really i'm gonna really
be
awful to him or i'm gonna try and take
him down and that tends to be like if a
woman's you know
like really beautiful you try and find
her faults but i don't know even the
score or something this is just
something i've observed i i gotcha i'm
stoked that there are gorgeous women and
frankly my idea of gorgeous i think is a
wider swath than
um hollywood or a lot of people's um i
find i find people being really genuine
really attractive and i find people
being really funny really attractive so
but
i mean she's just
eric is just a gorgeous gorgeous woman
that being said
let's get back to the scene and then
we'll continue
she's dressed up like a french maid
because she was she was trying to she
was in the luther mansion trying to get
information and that was her costume
okay
like she was like undercover as a french
maid
um and i was supposed to be like
aggressively
like attracted to her and kind of like
pushy
in like a is this a lesbian scene or is
this not is tess mercer a lesbian
what where's the sexual energy here
between these two women
um
kevin fair
really liked doing this but the one
thing i remember him saying after the
whole like first three takes he looked
at me and he was like he like took me
aside he's like cassie i have to tell
you something
and i was like so eager so eager to do
well and like
show up and be a good little
student and i was like yes what's up
what's up and he was like
you are eyebrow acting
and i was like what
and he's like you're just really
expressive in your face can you like
tone it down a little bit
once i guess from being on theater my
whole life i was like
were you just taken aback were you like
oh my god i don't know what to do here
how do i not do this or did you know
i took the note and i was like okay of
course it hurt it stabbed me to my core
that like it wasn't good i also didn't
understand that like we're gonna do 47
takes
and we're going to use three pieces of
like four of them and it's all going to
be two seconds yeah we take we take
every moment so seriously like oh my
gosh this is hours and hours of me just
doing this and they're going to get the
and they just need the best moments for
a few pieces
yeah and we forget that so every time
we're on set don't we yes yes we really
do we really do because we think
someone's like like um like what's that
what's that uh movie with um
where they're watching him all this time
being john malkovich
no well yes and
uh they're watching
tv uh jim carrey
yes jim carrey it was called truman show
truman show thank you ryan thank you god
2600 weeks um so
truman show you know that we think
someone's watching us all the time and
everything we do is being seen and
judged and is going to be in front of us
and it's not it's literally
that takes a lot of courage to be
to mess it up
so did you were you like after each take
did you say kevin is it less eyebrow
acting is that better no no i wasn't
that communicative or confident at the
time uh so what i did is i literally if
you watch the first three episodes that
i'm in season eight this is i do this
the whole time
did you think you were gonna get fired
by the way because i always feel like
i'm gonna get fired
i didn't you didn't you were like
did you audition for the part
i did because i had just done a cw pilot
i only had to test for
warner
horizon
i only had to test for warner really um
so but i did but it was a weird test
remember tests those aren't a thing
anymore either yeah they used to
bring out the best in me though and the
great thing about you know i always will
say i hate auditioning and
and by the way i read somewhere where
you said you love auditioning so let's
get to that but
uh [ __ ] you for that oh god but i i know
where did i say that sorry about my
f-bomb folks uh but i did i said it yeah
can i can i can i set off that phone you
can set off f-bombs i you know i i just
try not to but like you could say
whatever you want on the show i just i
just try not to say f-bombs a lot i'm
getting better right ryan
no i get it yeah i'm getting better i
don't think i f-bomb it too much or rose
and vomit too much but um oh what what
was i saying
or i'm talking about auditioning oh
auditioning yes i just get so worked up
and
the greatest thing you know about being
an actor sometimes you think is when you
get an offer and when you get an offer
you're like oh my god i didn't have to
audition for it i'm so cool yeah they
just offered me the role but it's the
hardest thing because then you're going
on set blindly and you you know you
don't know if what you're going to do is
what they're looking for and when you
test or when you audition you're giving
them if they like you this is what they
want so that's the that's the
that's you know that you were a choice
you it was a choice you know you showed
some cards and they were like i like
those cards i want that person
you can go in with some confidence
going in with an offer is kind of going
like am i being why am i being hired
they just know i'm going to be good they
just they're expecting greatness for me
that's what that is they're like oh yeah
we'll hire him because uh he's good but
they don't i always yeah i always
thought whenever my agents would say
something like this should be offer only
part of my brain would go then i don't
think i should do it
why
i mean i think that's someone else's
part not like if if it was the kind of
thing that oh you've done a lot of these
kind of guest stars they should know you
can do it so it should be offer only or
you know this is not that it's beneath
you but it's like stuff you've already
done
and my brain always went there are there
are other actors coming up that
need those roles
to like
get their chops to like figure it out
are you gonna take those are you saying
you wouldn't accept an offer
oh god no i i mean if i wanted to do the
project i would of course i would right
yes did you have you or by the way
quickly about auditioning why do you
like it so much
is it because of what we just talked
about
because that you like to get that you
want them to see what they're getting or
is it do you do you just really like the
pressure and stress and the [ __ ] of
it all and the rejection 90 percent of
the time
this feels like maybe a one-sided
argument i don't like the
i don't like driving there
but no one does that anymore anyway um
i don't like self tapes
nearly as much as i like going in the
room i just think i like performing
and when you're an actor in la and
you're not working on anything auditions
are your moment to perform
um and yeah sometimes they totally suck
sometimes it's like an assistant with a
latte and a dog doing the camera and
reading with you and you're like who's
gonna see this and how am i supposed to
connect with someone but
sometimes you really have these really
cool moments and i just have a lot of i
have a lot of feelings a lot of like
memories of coming out of auditions in
my 20s in la when i was like first
starting out
and just feeling like i had just hit it
out of the park
almost never booked it but that feeling
was so
visceral and like
i don't know maybe it's like little girl
from chicago but i was just like
hey so did you always want to be an
actress as a kid
yes i did
i did my mom lied when i was three and
um said i was five
and put me in ballet because i was
gigantic
and um
and it worked i had no verbal skills but
they didn't care they just thought i was
a very
not intelligent five-year-old and uh
and i
got on stage and i
i just loved dancing and
and then i got into acting i got it i
started auditioning for movies when i
was like nine i got an agent in chicago
i just loved it well your brother's
jealous i know you have three brothers
i do i have two biological and one
adopted
my adopted brother is not jealous
because he's uh he runs a really awesome
high school in chicago and he could care
less um i mean he supports me he loves
me but like it doesn't matter don't you
have a brother brothers
i thought you had a brother that's an
actor
i have two brothers that are actors both
my biological brothers are actors do
they ask you for your help what hey can
you get me on uh righteous gemstones
no but we worked together a lot and if
they did ask me i would say things like
i'd love to get whoever i want on the
righteous gemstones or or any show i'm
on i don't have that clap you don't have
that clout
i think people think that you have that
clout you the proverbial you because
right when i'm on smallville they're
like you know my friends are like hey
but i'm like dude they're hiring 99
guest stars that are canadian guest
stars and i have no say at least i
didn't have any say for years and years
uh you know it's really tough i remember
finally i was the lead on a series and i
was able to get a couple of my friends
on the on the show on a show but it's
it's very difficult to do that you have
to have i mean look even
brad pitt tries to get his friends and
stuff and it's it's it's not easy it's
like you have to be right for the part
that and i think you have to be one of
like the producers it has to be your
show
yeah i mean
and even then you have to fight for
things because they'll be like well we
can get someone with more twitter
followers
twitter you're like who you like
wow
i don't know i they actually took away
my verification because i didn't tweet
enough
what
that's impossible that's not a thing
it is it's a total thing they did it to
me you don't tweet enough so they took
away your verification
[Music]
is that what it is
did you fight back and say hey i'm
cassidy freeman
you know he didn't care no you don't
post a lot
twitter's like the lowest form of
communication what's the highest form of
communication
tick-tock
do you check
no i don't actually i don't are you not
going to send any new baby gg tick tocks
no
no it's not in you i mean posting your
kid online is like super controversial
anyway i'm just
i'm doing the best i can over here
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available 24
hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could
save i think you're doing really well
you seem like you're really together
you're kind of like in your seat kind of
twisting around doing your thing
you're confident you seem like you just
got your [ __ ] together
like that's really kind like i need to
call you for advice this time
20 years later
look you have my number you can always
call me yeah anytime anytime truthfully
do you
do you suffer from any anxiety do you
deal with stress things i remember i
knew i heard somebody in an interview
that you do have a little anxiety
have you had anxiety since you were a
kid and what does that feel like
i don't know we'd have to call my
therapist to see
how far back my anxiety
um i think everyone
at some point in their life or every
week as i do um
could benefit from talking to a
therapist
ryan right here ryan you don't see him
but my engineer he goes to therapy i go
to therapy you go to therapy yeah it's
not like everybody it's right for
everybody but i think it is is right for
everybody
yeah again not to project onto people
what they should or shouldn't do with
their lives but um
we used to live in communities with
elders that's what elders were
you know and you had a question or you
like wondered something and you like
went to the elder and the elder would
give you advice because they'd lived
life
now people go to google and google is
not an elder and either is tick tock or
some kid on you know whatever news
streaming thing there is
yeah this is me
no this is good this is good
but what about anxiety no but anxiety
wise is it something you had since you
were a child
i think i think so i think um
i've always been someone who needed to
[Music]
uh do really well i had i had a lot of i
i don't know from where it was imposed
but this feeling of perfectionism which
i think is like a
um
i think that's
goes kind of hand-in-hand with some
anxiety some people pleasing that's
that's what i
that's my issue is i'm always trying to
perfect everything to be great at
everything and it's just
i suffer because it's impossible it's
impossible to be great at everything to
be perfect at everything to be perfect
at anything it's it's there's no such
thing and yet with me if i'm not great i
feel like i failed
and that is a terrible way to live your
life and i have
started to get better about it i'm
starting you know i've been going to
therapy and working on myself but how do
you deal with that so what do you what
do you work on what do you do that first
of all you don't you don't give off that
vibe just so you know and i think that's
well i can't or i won't work
no one wants to see someone who's just
you know like that but um i try to be
honest about it on this podcast i try to
you know that's that's brave i like that
um what what do i do to battle that um
one of the things that i that someone
once asked me to do and i thought it was
really useful was
make a list mentally physically write
things down i write in a journal that's
like physical because i think that i
think it does something different than
typing
um actually being able to like write
with your hand and then see it in a
paper and tactile world which we're
losing um but i digress someone told me
make a list of the people that you
admire
and what you admire about them
and
and how many of those reasons are
because they're
perfect like what are the things that
make your skin you know you know when
you watch something or you hear
something or you see something and it
just kind of makes your skin feel alive
and you know that you're in the presence
of realness
whether that's like a concert you go see
um we just saw bonnie there in asheville
it was so beautiful or it's um or or
it's a stage production or it's someone
standing up for someone else's rights or
it's i don't know it's just those things
that i'm getting them now and those like
those feelings in your body where you're
like i'm in the i'm in the presence of
greatness
very rarely is that greatness perfect
very rarely does that greatness look or
smell or seem like how you think you
should be in order to be perfect and so
if we started actually giving props and
love and admiring the things that give
us that feeling rather than the things
that look a certain way or seem a
certain way
i think we'd have a better connection to
what is actually and what what is
actually perfect than using um quotation
fingers what
what do you who do you write when you
write what is it that you're writing
down who is it that you're writing down
oh i i write i just write like uh
i write to me i write like what i'm
feeling that day i also write weird
poetry
um
and sometimes things will just come to
me and i'll just i'll write them
uh what's weird
why is it weird
i don't know that's a great question
it's weird because sometimes it's campy
or it rhymes um and i think that's kind
of you know you think of poetry at least
when i learned poetry in college in high
school it was like uh the really
avant-garde stuff was supposedly
very smart
and rhyming was more like campy and kid
poetry or something right right and
sometimes really great poetry runs
sometimes it's pleasing to the ear
sometimes when you're like it's like
it's like um it's like it's like rap or
um freestyling or you know someone's
like going on this total train and then
they like hit that last word and it
actually rhymes and there's another
moment in your body when you're like oh
she said what
yeah
do you know what's so funny i'm thinking
about this and i'm laughing out loud
because it's so absurd
the way i think
i will write things
and
maybe inadvertently or
on purpose i'll be writing something
that resembles poetry or something
profound or something from the heart or
something and then i'll go
oh my god this is so pretentious if
anybody ever reads this which they're
not supposed to because it's just for me
it's just me writing to help express
myself but like i don't want to be
embarrassed when i'm dead
that's not crazy it's stupid so i erased
it because i don't want anybody to ever
read it if they ever read it they'll be
just like oh my god this guy is nuts
i have had this same exact why do we do
that i don't know anyone that hasn't had
this thought first of all but i also
kind of like i'll write things in code
to myself so that like if someone found
it they don't know what i'm actually
talking about
i have done that too i have done that
too with notes with notes that i'm
making i remember i um there were three
girls like a long time ago that i was
sort of seeing
but i in case anybody saw the email
they wouldn't no they wouldn't know if
they saw the piece of paper they
wouldn't know that their names are on it
so
so in other words if i was like kind of
talking to a girl named cassidy freeman
that'd say free
and then i have you know if somebody was
margo i put got
right that's right i mean so there's
code there's certain code that you put
to protect yourself but you know you'd
hope that no one ever finds this stuff i
mean if people found your stuff would
you be mortified
um
i think that's part of the letting go of
perfectionism
i think i think when i was in my 20s
absolutely even most most of my 30s but
i think now like
if i if someone found it honestly the
only thing i think is like if someone
reads this it's because i'm dead
right and who cares
and then i go like oh i want them to
know authentic me
oh wow and i'll go dark for a second my
mom passed away 10 years ago
and
her journal is one of the only things i
have left
um we all had it she wrote on a computer
because she was like very pragmatic and
like
and she
she wrote a lot about the cattle that
she raised which was not
super personal when you had a cattle
ranch in montana they had one right
yeah yep but like interspersed in
between like weights and like what
cattle were doing well and what weren't
um
there would be these little moments
where she'd be like i spoke to cassidy
today she sounds happy
you know or like i don't know i just i
loved getting to
to see those little moments of her so
you know maybe maybe this is all coming
to me now that i'm a new mom but
um i hope gigi has like
i don't know
she rates my journals first of all i
hope she has a
10 years to do so because there's a lot
of them but i think it'll be cool for
her to read
my weird mind but it sounds like it
meant a lot to you to hear your mom's
non-sequiturs of these random thoughts
of you that you were on her mind that
you were totally
so that's
that's pretty badass
yeah
yeah so keep writing in code if you have
to okay but i think i think it's
important do you guys i don't think
margot is gonna know that you wrote
about her tell me about your anxiety
though tell me about like what you what
you deal with what does it feel like
what does anxiety feel like for you
control
um
i've often described myself as a loving
controller
right and that's not other people i
don't like controlling people i have no
intention of doing that it's more like
situations my brain will try and find
the worst case scenario
and then already figure out how to get
out of the worst case scenario before
the thing even starts i know yeah
i can understand that
and then i'll be like i don't want to be
caught with my like ass out i don't want
to be like because why i don't know why
like
those moments though when we do fall on
our face and and and [ __ ] goes sideways
and we don't have control those are the
most magical moments so what what has
that happened when does that happen when
have you fell in your face one of you
i think it's why i love the stage i
think and
speaking specifically stage acting
versus film acting although i think it's
possible to find sometimes in film
acting with the right
circumstances that being said when you
start a play
a show
and the train leaves the station
and you're
whatever happens on stage happens
a light doesn't come you slip you fall
you're the props not there your partner
goes up like you know it just
it's so it's full improvisation
um which is probably why i love the job
i'm doing right now so much
the gemstones because these mother
suckers are incredible improvisers and
everything is just in the moment and
sometimes i find myself frustrated that
i i don't feel
i'm i feel like i feel
like slow
in the um in their presence often
because it's like their brains are going
so fast because they're not trying to
figure out how not to
how to fix things they're just like
super in the moment
um but it's great practice do you ever
get embarrassed do you ever get
devastated do you ever feel overwhelming
emotions or numbness or tingling with
anxiety or with just acting or anything
like that
i have gigantic emotions
yes gigantic explain gigantic
emotions
um yeah
these also happened as a kid because in
our house my parents
kind of didn't believe that big emotions
did a lot for you
um which is probably why we're all
actors
so in other words you'd lash out go i
don't care i hate you're like well
that's not working for you
no it was really anger wasn't really
where we where i went at least i would
go to like sadness um because i think
when we're kids we're like really tapped
into things unlike when we're adults
if i cried at something it would often
be like that's not gonna do anything for
you like it doesn't it doesn't
your parents would say that
they'd say that's not gonna do anything
for you
no my mom made me wear a shirt my mother
who i loved very much whenever i cried
she made me put a shirt on that had the
word sniveling with a circle and a line
for it
we don't do this we don't do this we
don't snivel it's not gonna help you
maybe that's what made you so tough and
made you feel like like you call it a
tomboy or whatever like you like be
wearing the boys because you don't do
you not cry that much are you not a
crier
oh no i'm i'm a crier you're you're
emotional in front of ben your husband
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah especially in the
last year with the hormones that have
been my reality
like i remember right after i had gigi
um someone oh it was the olympics which
are very controversial i guess but i
love the olympics and i love like i love
watching the olympics my brother and i
used to just watch them clark my little
brother we should just watch them like
obsessively
um
they come on and everyone right after
postpartum was like have you started
sobbing yet
and i looked at ben and i was like what
why why do people keep asking me that
like i'm not gonna stop and then this
commercial comes on
commercial
for
the special olympics and it was about a
pair of brothers
and one of them started to go blind
and the other brothers stayed with him
and they were doing some like long
distance skiing competition and they won
the gold in the special olympics and at
the end of this 30 second commercial i
am sobbing and controlling oh yeah
um
so yeah i cry i cry commercials but i'm
not like uh
if what you're asking is do i do i
immediately go there i don't but you
said gigantic emotions yeah they're just
big they're big emotions
yeah do you have any breakdowns have you
ever broken down on set
no and at work i don't do that well have
you ever broken down when you leave set
to go in your trailer
i've broken down on the drive home
and you're good because you're reliving
the day you're reliving what you did and
you feel like you failed
no no usually something happened on set
uh
that
some some something was handled in a way
that didn't feel safe to me in the
moment and i'm not talking anything
serious i'm just talking like
someone wasn't as nice to me or someone
didn't give me enough time to get ready
or someone
you know uh i've never experienced like
any kind of neglect or abuse on set in
that way but um
do you remember sypek
no
he was the he was the um on smallville
he and he may not have been there when
you were there but i think he was he was
the
uh pa for like the set pa or the base
camp pa
who would like hang out at trailers and
stuff and he would always knock on my
door and say like they're ready when you
are and i was at the beginning and be
like okay like
immediately busting out the door and
like ready to go and so eager and he he
was like the sweetest man and maybe his
40s really i have no idea how old he was
right and he kind of pulled me aside at
one point and he said cassidy don't be
so
ready i was like what do you mean she
was like just take a minute
take your time
wow
i've never heard of first ad or second
ad or any ad ever say that in the
history of film
i know usually it's like we need you
they need you on set and i'm usually
pretty good i'm usually like you know
within a minute or two i'm good like but
i always say this because after you get
to be
to do a lot of projects after you're on
set for a lot of hours a lot of days a
lot of years you start to question
authority a little bit and you start to
say things what you're supposed to would
you say
sigh
do they really need me on set right now
or
is no one else on set right now and i'll
be the first one and i'll be waiting for
15 minutes
and then psy will say
uh you could probably wait a few minutes
ago why don't you get me after they've
gotten any everyone else or in somewhere
in the middle
so you're not wasting time because a lot
of time on set is wasted time i could
not agree with you more and i remember
tom actually being really a great leader
in that way
where if he got called to set and he got
to set and he had to wait more than 10
minutes he would turn around and go back
to his trailer
yeah
shows yeah make them wait it was it was
it was funny because at first i was like
i don't know and then i was like oh
that's so smart
it's a lot of wasted time you're very
right and i will always remember psy for
that reason
do you do you like watching yourself
on like when i'm watching like when
you're watching gemstones or long mai or
smallville or oh yeah
yeah i love it i love it for a number of
reasons i love it because i get to
relive the fun of doing it
um i love it because i get to
[Music]
see what i did
and kind of go like
maybe next time or
i get to see the real moments that i i
like to study myself and others um i
don't love watching myself with other
people
i know i get that i get that yeah unless
you watched it already and you know
you're good then you can watch it with
other people and you're like ah watch
this this is gonna be good
yes but when you're in that like weird
horror movie that you don't know how
it's gonna turn out they're like come to
our screening and they're like i will
bring no one to that
if you watched yourself and god god i am
awful
yeah oh absolutely you have
yeah what have you thought you were
awful and if that's right you've washed
yourself and just been like
have you you've done that
i'll be honest the things that the
things that kind of make me cringe or
like sexy stuff
i don't have i'm not good at watching
myself so when you're sexting it up you
don't want anybody to see it nor do you
want to see yourself
so you just kind of like going up i
don't have to see that
who did you shut down did you sex it up
on smallville with anybody
like i'm my own dad i'm like i don't
want to see that i can't see that um
yeah i feel like i sexted up with
everyone on smallville
well we haven't really done
um yeah i had a whole thing with zod and
i had a thing with justin with green
arrow and then there was an alternate
universe where
tom and i clark kent and i wait you made
out with tom
yeah how was that
epic
i love that you just say that you just
like it epic were people like it was
fine everything was thomas really
professionally it was epic it was
happening no i say that because i
actually have a funny story remember
kelly soundbirds oh of course uh and
brian peterson
um kelly was directing that episode
it's just so embarrassing i can't
believe i'm gonna show you gotta share
it you gotta share it now
this is the being messy don't be perfect
um
so
that tom and i were always like friends
but obviously he's incredibly attractive
man and everyone on that show is
attractive let's just be honest
um that's why it's on the cw it's a
comic book show it was hard to be on i
always felt like i was the ugly duckling
i did forever oh my god yeah but go on
it's not about me are you serious i
swear to god i always felt like oh my
god they're gonna fire me because i'm
not i'm not as good looking as everybody
else that's how i felt in the beginning
and then i thought okay you're pretty
decent they're not going to fire you but
it took time
you should have called me because
literally everyone was like
oh you're here because uh michael left
good luck
no they did not oh yeah oh yeah they did
everyone you you'll never be as good of
an actor he's the best actor we've ever
had on this show what you probably show
together i'm not kidding i'm not even
like blowing smoke up your skirt they
really i was like well dang i better
bring my a game to match rosenbaum well
that's nice to say but it was uh yeah so
you were you were greatly loved
but um
tom i think tom and i were buddies and
so the and i don't think we ever thought
our characters would ever
go go to this place so then when it was
written in the script that it was like
an alternate universe and it wasn't even
there was nothing um
like romantic about it or like sweet it
wasn't like all of his and lois and
stuff where they're like smooch and like
sparkles around um it was very like they
already were dating and the alternate
universe versions were like obviously
like hardcore into each other so the
scenes were like one of us would come
and be the real and the other would be
the alternate so one of them was very
taken aback by the other one being very
forward
uh
and there's this one scene where where
tom comes into my office as alternate
tom
and like takes me and like aggressively
kisses me and i'm like
you know test mercer in the real world
is like what is happening and i'm
supposed to be like really shocked and
appalled and like grossed out
and about three takes in kelly pulls me
aside and she's like hey so talk to me
about what you think tess is feeling
this moment and i was like i feel like
tess is like surprised but also like
trying to be strong but doesn't really
know what's happening and she goes okay
cool because you're just smiling
the whole time
she's like ear to ear really big smiles
and i was like okay
[Laughter]
like so embarrassing oh my god
but he we both were very professional
and uh tom you know
there's certain yeah it's nice when you
can trust and be friendly with the
person
but watching it
is tough for me by the way last small
question that we can people on the
gemstone because i want to hear a few
things because uh uh
did you were you friendly with alice and
mack
yeah you guys yeah we used to like we
used to dogs at each other's dogs
really
strangely more
more communicative with her boyfriend
chad
at the time right at the time yeah
allison always had a lot going on
um
and
that didn't you know that was fine she
she had meetings she had girl groups
that i think i was invited to once and i
i it just wasn't wasn't my vibe but she
never she never got you to go into
one of those nexium things she never
asked you to do that nothing
never said hey this could be right for
you no
no and i actually remember asking her um
she invited me to like a ladies day at
her house and i couldn't come for some
reason i don't know if i was out of town
or something and part of me kind of felt
like oh i'm i'm left out but then i was
like i don't know how the ladies day is
my vibe um yeah so i just didn't i
didn't go and i'm glad i didn't
but i also i remember once asking like
oh what are you doing over hiatus she
was like i'm going to a poetry camp in
new york
and i was like cool
conversation ended there
really yeah
yeah i guess it was a shock to everybody
that's why i just kind of i was just a
little curious
as to in the final seasons is if there
were any kind of like communications
about it or like hey this would be right
for you try this out because who knows i
mean i always say like when i watch the
documentary because i had no idea that
hey you know insecure rosenbaum this
this is this is a thing that might be
good for me and then all of a sudden you
start to watch and you realize it's not
what it is but you don't know that going
in you think oh these people are really
supportive and it's building confidence
and it's uh it's all the you don't know
what it is and then you see the
the outcome and you're just
it's jaw-dropping so i just was curious
that and no i had i had no idea that
that was going on none whatsoever and i
guess i wasn't what they were looking
for but um
i i remember later coming back to
vancouver for a wedding and i had i
hooked up with some
uh for brunch with some people from the
show and we were having brunch and one
of the women was like
basically told me like you know
allison's in a cult that brands people
and i was like no
of course that's what everybody said no
i was like what are you talking about
no
and then like six months later it came
out yeah wow
um but yeah she had a dog named phantom
and i had shasta and they were buds
she was always you know we didn't hang
out a lot outside of set but she was
always really nice on set by the way
random non-sequitur if longmire came to
you and said we want to do a movie the
longmire movie or a short
new series would you do it
yeah you would
absolutely you loved doing it
i did who did you love working with on
that show
i loved working with um
a lot of our directors were really
awesome very
talented very uh efficient
chris chulack was um
he did our pilot and a a lot of our
season finales um
our camera department jimmy muro was our
one of our dps
um
and uh
he
he's like a legend he's like he was like
the original camera steadicam operator
um
and he whenever he directed he was
sometimes he couldn't find words he'd be
like
and i'd be like yes i think i know what
you mean and i think i'm gonna make that
happen uh but he just had so much
passion and he has such a beautiful eye
with the camera cameron duncan was our
other dp who was incredibly talented as
well
and um our crew was so badass uh
and i love working adam bartley's like a
brother to me um
he played the ferg and he and i
not only came from stage and you know
we're both cherubs
different years we just we came we were
cut from the same cloth and it felt
really familiar
and fun to be with him and katie sackoff
as a total supporter
rad chick to be on the show
she's been on the show a couple of times
she's she's an awesome awesome person
yeah we're still we're still dear
friends and um i can't believe we had
kids so close together um
and uh i can't think of anyone that
wasn't awesome lou diamond phillips is a
sweetheart and and so
like eager to do new things and um rob
is just
rob rob is rob robert taylor who was our
sheriff um all the way from australia
he was just authentic as hell you light
up and right up and i said i mentioned
longmire i just that you just did i
didn't have to say much you just kind of
open up about wow it sounds like you
would do this in a heartbeat this was
like a family to you
yeah yeah they really were i love it
they really were a family but the
gemstones the righteous gemstones your
amber gemstone you're you're playing in
a with a legendary cast
with john goodman and danny mcbride
you're danny mcbride's wife amber um i
haven't watched all that i've watched
two episodes i i was kind of just blown
away it's just kind of
absolutely
nuts and i understand what you say when
it's like you get a little bit it's
overwhelming sometimes and all these
people who their minds just keep going
and keep going and you're trying to play
catch-up um
what is it that paint the picture where
you're in a scene and everybody's
improvising what do you do do you try to
step up and you're trying to be on their
level you're just like know your lines
know the scene know where it's going and
just just react listen and react what do
you do
um because you never know what's coming
at you with danny mcbride
you don't
you don't no you don't and i love that
um
this is it isn't it is an incredible
cast of people to be working with i feel
so lucky i have by the way i have to be
honest with you i'm gonna i'm like i'm
only cutting you off for a second then i
want you to continue cut me off but when
i watch it i i love john goodman he's
one of my favorites of all time he's
just a brilliant actor but when i see
him on this set in the hot charleston
south carolina i have to imagine he's
the biggest pain in the ass in the world
and wants to be upset like i could just
imagine him wanting to like going get me
off the set are we done here no no no
he's so he's the opposite he is thank
god i thought for sure he'd be miserable
oh
no we're always worried we're like are
we gonna really are we gonna give john
heat stroke are we like what's happening
because he won't leave set he'll be like
no let's do it again let's do it again
and someone will be like let's rest in
the cooling tent and that's like you
know
have a drink of water good no let's go
like he's so
he's so dedicated he's really hard on
himself in a really
like
interesting way i don't want to say cute
or adore like i i i like it because i
identify with it someone who holds
themselves to high standards i think you
probably can too given our conversation
right
um he's not at all he is he is such a
team player uh almost to a fault
almost almost sometimes to uh to all of
us because because we you know
those are very hot days and this season
in particular which we just started
shooting i just had my first week of
work
last week um
we started the season in june so it is a
scorcher out there
um by the way
what do you do though what do you like
how do you know first off how do you not
laugh well finish your thought dan i'm
sorry finish your thought on
the improv and it's all around you and
people are throwing [ __ ] around you and
what are you feeling like
yeah look if look if i that's a good
question and what do i do in that moment
because there have been other
interviewers or people who have kind of
described amber specifically actually
eli and amber as sort of meaning john
goodman's character being the the
straight people in like a wacky world um
i actually think amber's wacky in her
own way but she's not the same kind of
wacky so if it was if cassidy was doing
an improv with edie and danny and adam
and tim and you know that would be i
would maybe act differently but amber is
not trying to one-up amber is uh she
watches and then she makes like these
strikes whenever she calculates so
calculating yes she's calculating that's
a great that's a great word and and she
um
and she but she's also emotional and she
and she's sensitive
um everyone in the show is it's just
i love that this kind of comedy is
comedy based in these characters being
really real in their own world of mine
but to the to the you know to the
outside world to the people who are
watching it they are
out of their [ __ ] minds
at their own world are so cool danny
mcbride is my favorite comedian
now
i tested for eastbound and down for the
last season and almost got it and he
came up to me at a party and was like
you don't know how close you were we
were gonna we're gonna get you cast we
gotta bring you in something else and
then there was something that they were
auditioning or uh was i was up for for
this season of um
of gemstones but i couldn't do it
because i'm not available but i'm like
it was like i know it's awesome it's
some kind of cousin
character some kind of crazy you
probably know already don't you why
aren't you available i know wouldn't
that be awesome i mean it's just like
that but he is like my
it's like my dream to work with him and
just go just be on the set with him and
like what is something you remember can
you remember so how hard a is it to keep
a straight face when he's improvising
and throws [ __ ] at you
how often do you break character and
laugh
and see
um what's the funniest thing he's ever
said
that you remember that you just could
not keep a straight face
okay a how do i not laugh i do laugh and
i does it get mad actually
no no no no one ever gets mad at
laughing i feel worse when i laugh off
camera because then i'm [ __ ] it up
for them
um because i can't hold it in uh
i know amber i think does a lot of like
looking down because cassidy is gonna
lose her mind uh
what was b b was um
what happened we laugh a lot
there's a lot there's a lot of laughing
especially um i think the amount of
laughing during improvisations in that
show
could be
directly linked to what time of day it
is that we're shooting so those 3 a.m
scenes
where we're all just like super luke we
were gonna have to just like add an hour
to that day because there's gonna be a
lot of laughing and no no one gets mad
i can't think and i'm going straight to
see i'm really going to answer your
questions here i don't think there's one
thing that i can
think that danny has said
that has made me
the things that make me laugh the most
honestly is when he laughs when some
when something tickles him
it
it's the greatest thing ever have you
made him laugh
yeah yeah yeah i have and it makes me
and he'll tell me about it too that's
also what i love he'll like text me or
be like i love that part he's so
he's so kind and he's so gracious um and
he has no sense of like
uh ego or it's just it's just really
incredibly
warm and inviting and safe uh and he'll
let you know when you did a great job
and it just feels really nice
uh i love it uh righteous gemstone
season four is coming out
three season three i don't wanna jump
the gun
we're shooting season three right now we
had to we lost a year to coven right
right
um
quickly vampire diaries do you go to
comic cons do you ever sign autographs
for vampire diaries do people ever come
up and notice you from vampire diaries
we just took a hard left turn uh
yeah they i i don't sign autographs for
vampire diaries um not because i
wouldn't i just have never really been
asked and uh
i do get recognized
by very specific i i can
a fun game when someone goes like i love
your work
is for me to go
what are they talking about
do they know me that's a which one so
that's a fun game yeah i go like what do
they what do i think they've seen don't
don't i love when people come up to you
and go what have i seen you in
that's just like oh come on don't come
up to me
don't do it don't [ __ ] do it just you
know what if you recognize me from
something come up to me and say i loved
you on that or i liked you on that or
you could have been better on that but
don't say what do i because i look like
an idiot
coming up with what i think you saw me
in
that's a horrible thing to do i know
it's small but what you should do is go
to go to imdb pro and just look me up
and then you tell me
you tell me yeah no because i've said
most time ago oh it's gotta be small
though like a small buddy no
no i did that once and when i was when i
was first on smallville and i was like
well i'm in smallville and they're like
it's not that and i think they actually
knew me from like the neighborhood which
was really embarrassing
uh
but no no one does that to me that's
awful i think that's an l.a thing
i think people do that in l.a because
they assume when they recognize them
when it's from something right living in
santa fe and
being in the south a lot for charleston
and charleston and
the surrounding area a lot of people
will go
now are you my church group
how do i know you
do you go did you go to school with my
son
and i'll be like did you watch a show
called longmire and they'd be like oh
hell yeah i did that's exactly what i'm
thinking
yeah oh you're you're katie longmire
no
you're or this is this your longmire's
dirt
please that's the yeah
i got that last weekend you're
longmire's dirt
i just i love that i was watching he was
on turlet
[Music]
this is called [ __ ] talking with cassidy
freeman folks uh if you're a patreon if
you're a top patreon go to
patreon.comcity you get to ask questions
uh the top tiers get to ask questions
and thanks for the support uh of the
podcast this is [ __ ] talking with cassie
freeman this is rapid fire we're gonna
ask you fan questions and you just boom
rapidly go
this has been terrific it's going by so
fast
nico what's one of your biggest pet
peeves ooh
for some reason i wanted to say nails on
a chalkboard but no one actually ever
does that i just hate that sound yeah
it's bad um chewington one of my pet
peeves is people telling you
uh what you should do people telling you
what you should do
you know what you should do
yeah
yeah people always say that you know i i
do that too well you know what you
should do ryan you should go up yourself
because i ain't listening to your stupid
advice oh my god you should totally like
you know get get your chart read by this
person oh my gosh you have to get these
sneakers they'll make your back feel
better for days oh my god yeah no little
lisa can you please share any funny
behind the scenes stories while filming
smallville anything funny quickly
funny
justin hartley trying to lift me in his
green arrow shoes that were heels and uh
both of us almost falling over every
single time
that's funny amazing super sam
tess went through a huge change from her
introduction to the final episode to the
point of being completely different
person at the end did you know that
would be happening when accepting the
role
no i had no idea
what tess mercer's uh journey was going
to be and i thought it was really cool
when she kind of became part of
watchtower
when did you find out that lex luthor
was going to come back in season 10 and
kill you
we're talking about ourselves in the
third person
not until very late i honestly there was
a lot of like
uh talk of whether you would do it
i called them two weeks before or a week
and a half before or something like that
and i just said hey you guys got me for
next friday
whatever you want to do you had me for
the full day
yeah
that was yeah i hope he's back i want
rosie back
yeah and we got to do a scene out of all
that time we we got to do a scene
together
and i got to kill my sister
and i got to erase your memory you did
you [ __ ]
will f omg i loved longmire how was it
working with robert taylor what you
already said a loon diamond phillips you
already said that
okay well
done you love them bob k any possibility
of a longmire movie i asked that too and
i you said you would do it if it was i
would do it i have no idea all right
raj tell me about a time someone
unexpectedly showed you kindness
that's a beautiful question there really
is and it's something we don't think
about often isn't it
it really is
something we don't think about often
something kind of it could be anything
it'd be opening the door for you it
could be
right well i was gonna say i've been
traveling a lot with my newborn alone
and the amount of people who have
offered to
help me with my bags hold her
snap that carrier thingy on my back
help me put a car seat in a bag like
they're really
men and women um
there are plenty of people who breathe
by me not giving a [ __ ] but the people
that that ask are really kind and that's
i think it gives me
warm fuzzies
love you and gemstones i asked you this
but she this person wants to know uh how
hard is it not to break character in
that show honestly is it a heart is it a
very difficult thing to kind of keep
that face to keep in character
i mean you get you you get used to it
and you kind of get to know what kind of
jokes each character might come up with
but then there are some things that just
hit you sideways and everyone loses
their minds
like if you've seen the beginning of
season two which you haven't but you
might um
there's this whole scene about disney
characters that's all i'll say none of
that was written and it was
hilarious
really it just goes on and on
it just goes on and on like i think our
camera department must hate us
um because we just never we just keep
going so you don't cut you the video
still rolls and rolls for if you have a
one-page scene it might be 20 minutes
for that one scene
that's correct
so you never know like you know the
scene has already ended and you're still
doing this scene
yes that's right and you like doing it
yes
yes
yeah because that's where the magic
happens is it exhausting though it is
exhausting isn't it
you know what's exhausting is is take
take
15 is exhausting
you would hope that it could be a little
shorter um no the improv the improv days
are not exhausting that i think i mean
for i'm speaking from me i think the
crew would tell you differently um for
me those days are not exhausting the
exhausting days are the logistical days
where you're like everyone's walking in
and this person and that person you know
you don't say anything but you're like
you gotta do things over and over again
to get timing right that can be
exhausting but it's all part it's all
part of the process you know so many
people ask me when is cassidy freeman
coming on the podcast i've really i've
truly
truly had that question asked quite
often and i'm i'm so glad that you and i
finally got a chance to sit down and
talk it's been a
tremendous treat i hope it was fun for
you
super fun i feel like we could go on and
on i really do but we'll save that for
maybe next time
we'll definitely do it next time i'm so
proud of you i'm so happy for you and
ben and gigi she's the cutest little
girl and is it difficult uh
working
is it does it make working harder when
you have a little one
learning lines all those things
nah she makes everything better what an
answer perfect answer uh thank you for
allowing me to be inside of you today
this has been a real treat
listen
yes feelings mutual all right i love you
and i wish you only the best and we will
talk soon
okay great okay
bye
uh all i could say is i i love cassidy
frame she's cool that was a fun
interview and uh
she's such a sweetheart
it's cool now that i'm starting
righteous gemstones
season two
it's cool uh seeing her in it having
talked to her now she's really good in
that she's really funny yeah i had an
opportunity to maybe be on that show and
i turned it down
opportunity for the you know
yeah
i let my anxiety get in the way folks
uh anyway uh that was really fun uh if
you want to listen to all the
information i gave you in the uh opening
of this podcast just rewind go back
there's tons of stuff about the inside
of you online store and patreon make
sure you join patreon to support the
podcast if you can it really helps i
love my patrons go to patreon.com inside
of you right now i'm going to do a
little reading of all the top tier names
who make this podcast really possible
also thank you to westwood one our
cumulus and to ryan teos to bryce my
producer congratulations he just had a
little baby beckham
so bryce mollers make sure you send him
a a message
uh congratulating him cute little baby
and i'm very happy for him and logan
and uh yeah i love the guy
that's cool yeah he's good that comes
the name of the baby beckham beckham
beckham
here we go beckham
uh top tiers here they are nancy d leah
s sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
bryan h nico p robert b jason w kristen
k raj c joshua g rosh joshua deed cj p
jennifer and stacy l
jamal f janelle b kimberly e mikey
yelled on soprano 99 more ramirez
santiago m chad w leanne p maya p maddie
s belinda
n correct chris h davey sheila g
brad d ray h tabitha t tom and suzanne b
liliana a talia m betsy d chad l marion
uh meg k dan and big stevie
w correct angel ann marie nc
cory k devnex and michelle a jeremy c
andy t gavinator david c
what was that they're dog barking oh
john b brandy d yvore camille s the
c
joey m design
otg eugene and leah
chris p nikki g corey kdb nicole
patricia heather l jake b james b megan
t
mel s orlando c caroline r rob e paul c
christine s sarah s eric h
jennifer r
and last but not least shane r
m r
mark m jeremy
jeremy
jeremy v andrew m robert gzatoichi77
andreas n alexandra chris r michael f
samantha w michelle d
you guys rock i love saying your names i
don't care how long this list is you're
supporting the podcast i love you i
thank you thanks for supporting the
podcast thanks to my guest cassidy
freeman for spending a nice hour with us
and getting to know her and getting to
know what makes her tick
and uh
be good to yourselves today
we give yourselves every week you only
got you so look after you get that
therapy if you need it you know take a
walk if you need it
play goalie if you need it play goalie
if you need it
i need to um you yeah apparently
apparently uh i'm michael rosenbaum from
the hollywood hills in california i'm
ryan tez from the same location
nice wave over to you
and uh thank you so much and we'll see
you next week
you